today I'm going to talk about the seven
habits that you need to stop doing right
now I believe that those entrepreneurs
that you have not hit your ceiling that
you could be doing a lot more than
you're doing right now that you have
greater potential inside you than what
is being realized right now and in order
to do that you have to stop doing the
seven habits consistently to help you
break through and achieve your higher
goals
number one is stop blaming others if
something doesn't go your way
the default for so many people is to
blame somebody else right it's my
brother's fault it's my parents fault
it's the government's fault it's my
friend's fault right it's never your
fault is always somebody else's fault
and until you start taking
accountability for your life for what
you're doing right now for the situation
that you're in as long as you put it on
somebody else as long as you abdicate
that responsibility and say it's his
fault or her fault then you're never
going to change we have to understand
that you are responsible you need to
take accountability if the people around
you sucked and change your environment
that's on you you're staying in this
crappy environment that's your fault so
stop blaming others and start taking
action
number two is stop making excuses this
is kind of tied to number one but
instead of blaming other people you're
blaming your circumstances you know
you're saying oh I can't do it because
it's playoff season I don't have the
time to do it or I can't do it because
the economy is really bad or I can't do
it because I just don't have the time
this week and then it's one excuse after
another excuse after another excuse
there is never a perfect time to start a
business there's never this magical
perfect time you will always have things
that are pushing your time down you'll
always have constraints you will never
have enough money you'll never have
you'll never have enough time to
dedicate to start in this business you
need to make the time you need to make
it a priority I need to stop making
excuses again you are where you are
right now because of you that's it that
might be a harsh truth but until you
recognize that you're never going to
grow as long as you blame the other
people as long as you're blaming
something else something else out there
besides the person that you can look at
in the mirror until you take that
responsibility until you accept that
role until you fully believe that I have
the power to change my circumstances and
I am the only one to blame do you really
believe that you're going to stay where
you look so stop making excuses
number three is stop criticizing
yourself
I think we're too hard on ourselves as
human beings but especially as
entrepreneurs we have these big bold
ideas and then immediately we start
thinking well Who am I to do that I
can't do that I didn't go to school for
that you know I'm not good enough to do
that I tried doing that once and it
didn't work out and we're constantly
beating ourselves down you look at how
entrepreneurs price their products and
services and it's often way lower than
it than what it should be
and until you start valuing your time
your experience the way it should then
other people won't value you either
right people will value you the way you
value yourself people will treat you the
way you treat yourself so if you're
constantly beating yourself down other
people will beat you down too and so you
need to start building up the confidence
in yourself you need to create a great
environment around yourself that helps
you believe in yourself more and believe
that you can play a game that's up here
instead of the one that's down here so
stop criticizing yourself you start
believing in yourself
number four is you need to stop settling
and this is a really tough one
because I think we settle way too much
you know we have these standards and
then we let them slide and we settle for
things that are that are just good you
know we put a lot of work into something
and then we see how much work it would
need to take to get it to that next step
and so we we don't do it we settle we
stop and too many people settle for
average you settle for mediocre you set
up we're just okay in all areas of your
life right you settle for an okay
relationship you set up for okay
customers you set up for an okay
business you never push yourself to go
for something great and if it's if it's
really bad you're going to change it
right if you have really bad customers
who are just yelling at you all the time
then you're going to fire them and move
on but it's the customers that are just
okay and a product that it's just okay
and the husband or wife that is just
okay or the relationship that's just
okay it's just good until you never
change it and you settle for good and if
you want to go and do something great
then you have to have high standards and
you have to stick to those standards
standards in in how other people treat
you and standards in how you treat
yourself stop settling for okay and
average and start achieving to higher
standards
number five you need to stop living
someone else's life
too often we make decisions in our life
in our business based on what other
people want right your parents want you
to do something your customers want you
to do something you know your friends
want you to do something Society wants
to do something and you're spending so
much of your time living up to other
people's expectations that you don't
ever even create a life of your own you
do this because it's what you're
expected to do not because what you want
to do and what you really want to do is
hard because that path isn't defined you
don't know how it's going to work out
you're drawn into a direction but you
don't know if that path is going to work
or not and it's scary and it's risky and
you don't have the people behind you to
go and make that happen and so because
it's so scary you don't do it where if
you live up to somebody else's
expectations that's defined right like
hey I want you to do this I want you to
take care of that and so it's easier to
do that because there is that path but
you're helping build somebody else's
dream instead of working on building
your own you need to stop living other
people's lives and start living your
version of your life
number six is stop complaining people
from my experience who are huge
complainers don't get very far when you
talk to burn you ask how their day is
going all you hear is negativity law
this didn't work out and all that guy is
such an idiot and you know just one
negative thing after another where it is
really hard being an entrepreneur right
it's going to be one of the hardest
thing to ever do in your life and the
thing that gets you through is one the
love for what you're doing and to the
optimism that it's going to work out
like you have to hold on to goodness to
get you through all the crap that's
involved in running a business and
successful entrepreneurs are never the
complainers they're never the ones who
are blaming other people back to the top
of the episode but they aren't the ones
who just walk in every day and are just
complaining about things and yes you
have really really bad down dates and
it's not that you're always optimistic
100% of the time but you do not want to
be the person who is just constantly
complaining and to take it a bit further
you don't want to be surrounded by
people who are constantly complaining
because they bring you down and their
negative energy makes you be more of a
complainer where if you surround
yourself with people who are uplifting
optimistic who believe who are trying to
do big things
then you will as well and you will
eventually do those big projects and
achieve your goals
so stop complaining and start being more
optimistic
and number seven is stop talking and
start doing how many people do you know
who just talk a big game you talk about
the things that one day they're going to
do that someday is on their plan that
just keep adding to their bucket list
and never actually do it the people who
just have all these great ideas but then
they sit at a job working on the 5 that
they hate and they never follow through
on any of the things that they have
these big dreams for stop being a talker
stop being the person who just shouts
out ideas and then gets upset when
somebody else goes and does it that's
not their fault for beating you to your
idea you didn't execute that's on you if
you have something that you want to do
go out and start doing it it may be some
big dream and that's amazing but find
the smallest way to get started you want
to dream big and start small a lot of
people have these big dreams and they
don't know where to start there's no
magical one beautiful place to start you
just start you start and you take
another step and you take another step
and as you start taking your steps the
path reveals itself where so many people
are too afraid to take that first step
they don't know how to get started and
then that dream just stays there is a
dream and then you watch somebody else
go and execute and achieve that dream
instead of you so stop talking stop
talking about the things that one day
you're going to do and start doing so
those are the seven things that I think
you need to stop doing right now if you
want to start achieving success in your
business I'd love to know what you think
of the 7 I'd love to know which of the
ones is holding you back the most right
now be honest leave in the comments
below and if you think I'm missing
something from the list add it in as
well in the comments and I will join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon